Okay, so we can also take in
an input of a non object and
maybe even an empty matrix.
Is that right?
>> Right.
>> Hm, so we have our regular matrix so
that we're taking in,
but it contains zeroes and
ones, nothing else, right?
>> That's true.
>> So this is also another
input that we can have.
So here we started thinking
through tests and edge cases for
inputs into the algorithm.
As you may have noticed,
when he was creating edge cases,
he thought of the possible weird
inputs that he would have to handle.
>> Right, if there were other values
that could have been used in his matrix,
he would have to account for those.
It's always a good idea to think
about how your code handles null and
empty inputs, since not addressing
them could cause your code to crash.
>> You know what is great about
this step in the approach,
is I have a feeling it
might help in future steps.
>> Let's see.